rice a simple word yet it represents
sustenance for billions across our
planet from the bustling streets of
Bangkok to the Tranquil Countryside of
Vietnam rice is more than just a food
it's a way of life but how often do we
pause to consider the Journey of this
humble grain join me now as we delve
into the fascinating world of rice
cultivation we'll uncover the secrets of
this aquatic crop from its submerged
Beginnings to the golden waves of
harvest
our journey commences in the heart of
rice country where the land sculpted
over centuries lies ready to receive its
most precious offering the rice seed but
before a single grain can be sewn the
stage must be meticulously set Farmers
with an innate understanding of their
land begin the laborious task of
preparing the fields the soil rich and
fertile from generations of rice
cultivation is first carefully plowed
transforming the earth into a canvas of
soft welcoming furrows leveling follows
ensuring an even distribution of water a
crucial element in the life of a rice
plant this is no ordinary crop rice
thrives in water logged conditions its
roots drawing sustenance from the
flooded Fields with the stage set the
planting begins some Farmers scatter
seeds directly onto the water's surface
a method known as direct seeding others
opting for a more controlled approach
carefully transplant young seedlings
their Roots already accustomed to the
Aquatic environment these delicate
shoots nurtured in nurseries stand
poised on the brink of a remarkable
transformation as days turn into weeks
the flooded Fields shimmering mirrors
reflecting the sky become a Haven for
Life the rice plants their Roots
anchoring them in the mud below stretch
Skyward their leaves of vibrant green
against the Azure canvas above the
flooded Fields team with activity tiny
fish Dart between the stalks their
presence a natural form of pest control
insects drawn by the abundance of Life
Buzz lazily in the warm air their role
in the delicate balance of this
ecosystem equally vital the farmer a
constant Guardian carefully monitors the
water levels ensuring the rice plants
remain submerged their Roots nourished
by the life-giving water it's a delicate
dance between land water and human
intervention a testament to the
Ingenuity and resilience of generations
past the flooded Fields reveal their
true beauty to those who take the time
to observe they are a testament to the
harmonious relationship between humanity
and nature a partnership forged over
Millennia and as the sun dips below the
Horizon casting Long Shadows across the
water the rice fields transform into a
scene of ethereal Beauty
weeks melt into months and the once bare
Fields undergo a remarkable
transformation the tiny rice seedlings
nourished by the sun and the rich
fertile water have flourished their
slender stalks reaching Skyward their
leaves unfurling like Emerald banners
the Patty Fields once a canvas of brown
and blue are now a vibrant sea of green
stretching as far as the eye can see the
air thick with the humidity of the
tropics hums with the sound of Life
dragonflies their wings shimmering
iridescent in the sunlight Dart amongst
the stalks while frogs bask on the
leaves they're croaking a constant
serenade the rice plants now in their
vegetative stage are a testament to the
power of Nature's resilience their Roots
firmly anchored in the muddy depths draw
up nutrients and water fueling their
growth their leaves reaching for the sun
capture the energy needed to transform
sunlight into food a process essential
for life on Earth the farmer a constant
presence in this watery World carefully
monitors the growth of his crop he knows
the signs to look for the subtle changes
in color that indicate the plants are
thriving he walks the narrow ridges
between the patties his trained eyes
scanning for any signs of pests or
disease as the weeks progress a
remarkable transformation takes place
the rice plants having reached maturity
begin to flower tiny delicate blooms
emerge their pale green Hues a stark
contrast to the vibrant green of the
leaves these flowers pollinated by the
wind and the insects that called The
Patty Fields home hold the key to the
next stage of the rice plant's life
cycle the formation of the grains slowly
almost imperceptibly at first the rice
grains begin to swell each grain a tiny
capsule of Life contains the potential
to nourish and sustain the farmer his
heart filled with pride watches as the
fields gradually transform from a sea of
green to a shimmering expanse of gold
the time for Harvest the culmination of
months of hard work and dedication is
finally at hand the air heavy with the
scent of ripe grain carries a sense of
anticipation for the farmer this is a
time of both celebration and relief a
time to reap the rewards of his labor in
many parts of the world the Harvest is
still a communal Affair a time for
families and neighbors to come together
and help bring in the crop the rhythmic
swishing of sickles cutting through the
stalks the laughter and chatter of the
Harvesters and the gentle rustling of
the rice plants create a symphony of
sound a testament to the enduring
connection between humanity and the land
the harvested rice stalks heavy with
golden grains are carefully gathered and
bundled ready for the next stage of
their Journey the transformation from
plant to
plate the Journey of rice however is far
from over harvested from the flooded
Fields the bundles of rice stalks now
embark on a new leg of their
transformation one that will see them
shed their outer layers and emerge as
the polished grains we recognize the
first stage of this process known as
threshing involves separating the rice
grains from the stalks traditionally
this was done by hand beating the stalks
against a hard surface to release the
grains today however machines have
largely taken over for this task
increasing efficiency while preserving
the Integrity of the grain freed from
their stocks the rice grains still
encased in their protective husks
undergo a process known as hulling here
large machines gently loosen the husks
allowing the brown rice grains within to
emerge these husks far from being
discarded are often used as animal feed
or as a source of fuel highlighting the
resourcefulness inherent in traditional
agricultural practices the brown rice
grains their outer layers removed are
now ready for the next stage of their
transformation Milling
this process involving a series of
rollers that gently rub against the
grains removes the bran layer revealing
the white rice within the brand rich in
nutrients and fiber is often saved and
sold separately a testament to the
growing awareness of the health benefits
of whole grains the white rice grains
now polished to a pearly Sheen undergo a
final inspection ensuring only the
highest quality grains make it to the
consumer sorted by size and quality the
rice is then packaged ready to be
shipped to markets and supermarkets
around the world the Journey from field
to package is a testament to human
Ingenuity and Innovation over centuries
farmers and processors have developed
techniques and technologies that
maximize efficiency while preserving the
quality and nutritional value of the
rice but it's important to remember that
behind every bag of rice lies a story a
story of hard work dedication and a deep
connection to the land from the farmers
who toil in the fields to the workers
who operate the processing machines
countless individuals play a role in
bringing this staple food to our tables
the next time you reach for a bag of
rice take a moment to appreciate the
journey it has
taken our journey reaches its
culmination not in a bustling
Marketplace or a crowded Supermarket
aisle but at a simple table set for a
family meal the aroma of freshly cooked
rice as scent familiar to billions
around the world fills the air a sensory
reminder of the journey this humble
grain has taken from the flooded Patty
Fields where Farmers toiled Under The
Tropical Sun to the sophisticated
processing plants where ancient
techniques meet meet modern technology
each step in the Rice's Journey has
played a vital role in bringing this
staple food to our plates as we lift our
Chopsticks or spoons ready to partake in
this shared Bounty it's worth reflecting
on the interconnectedness of our world
the rice that nourishes us today may
have been grown on a small family farm
in Vietnam harvested by hand in the
traditional way or cultivated on a vast
mechanized operation in the American
Midwest regardless of its origin the
rice that Graces our tables is a
testament to human engineer uity
resilience and our enduring connection
to the natural world it's a reminder
that even in our increasingly globalized
Society we are all connected by the food
we eat and the farmers who grow it so as
you Savor the taste of that perfectly
cooked grain of rice remember its
journey and so our journey through the
rice patties comes to an end we've
witnessed the intricate dance between
nature and human endeavor the ancient
rhythms of planting and harvest and the
remarkable transformation from Humble
seed to a life- sustaining grain but
more than just a food rice represents a
way of life for billions as we've seen
the Journey of rice is a testament to
the power of collaboration from the
farmers who cultivate the land to the
families who gather to share a meal